[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CLAPPING]
SCOTT: And take it away.
ERIN GLEESON: Thank you.
Thank you, Scott, and thank you
everybody for taking time out
of your day to come.
I really appreciate it.
So if you can see a screen
from where you're sitting,
my talk goes along
with a slideshow.
So I'm going to take it back
a second to the beginning.
I grew up in
northern California.
I grew up in Sonoma County
just a couple of hours
north of here.
And I grew up out
in an apple orchard.
And it was a pretty
bucolic setting.
My parents had a big
vegetable garden.
We cooked with vegetables
and fruits a lot.
We were actually vegan
for most of my growing up.
I'm not anymore.
But that was the basis of
my learning how to cook
and what I was exposed
to, which has definitely
informed what I'm doing today.
So as a kid, I was really
into photography and painting.
I took a watercolor
painting classes
from the time I
was five years old.
And then I always had one
of those disposable cameras
that I took around with me.
And I was taking photos
and setting up my cousins
for photo shoots in the
backyard and in the orchard.
And those two elements
have really come together
in my recent work.
So for college, I
studied art and I
come from a family that's
very supportive of that.
So my parents were like,
great, be an art major.
Not sure what you're going
to do next, but awesome,
we support you.
And then after that, I
graduated from college,
I decided that I was
going to move to New York
to become a photographer.
And I didn't really
know what that meant.
But I knew I loved
photography and I
knew all the
magazines were there,
and so I just thought I'd go
and try it, maybe for a year.
But it ended up being
about nine years.
So during that time,
I worked at a magazine
and a photo department and for
several different photographers
in their studios.
And I also babysat and
worked at a restaurant
and walked dogs and
did a million things
to try and kind of be
an artist in New York.
And then finally,
I decided that I
was going to go back
to school because I
wanted to teach photography.
And so, that takes me
to this first slide
which is two different photos
that I took in grad school.
I went to school visual arts
and I did an MFA in photography.
And they sort of said
in the beginning,
go out and take photos of
whatever you're drawn to
and then bring
them back and we'll
see what your focus might be.
And I just kept seeing
myself taking photos of food.
It was just all these
colors and textures.
And I was just so drawn
to food in general.
But because I was
vegetarian, I ended up
shooting a lot of desserts,
because they're colorful,
they're vegetarian, they're
delightful to shoot,
they have all the texture.
But I wasn't really
satisfied with just
taking a photo of them like on
a table or on a white backdrop.
So I started playing around
with these other elements.
So this photo right
here-- or these two photos
are pages that I took
out of magazines.
And I propped them in the
back of Data Studio setup.
And I was trying to create
this little fantastical world
for a desert.
And I wanted them
to be funny and
silly and colorful and playful.
So this is just the early
days of my photography.
And I think it's actually very
similar to what I'm doing now.
There's a lot in
the middle though.
So here's a few more
of those desert shots.
You can see there's different
pages from magazines
in the backdrop,
sort of pretending
as if these deserts are
placed in an old palace
or in a grand ballroom.
So these are examples of
two different photographers
that I was really
influenced by at this time.
The one on the right,
the watermelon--
sorry, on your left,
is by Irving Penn
who is a famous photographer.
He shot a lot for "Vogue,"
he did a lot of fashion,
but also a lot of still life.
And his images are very much
setup, very purposefully styled
and put together.
So that watermelon is
perfectly placed there
with that bread
in the foreground
and those grapes
in the background.
And that was his setup
shot versus the other shot
is by Martin Parr.
And he's a photographer
who is still working today.
And he's a photojournalist.
So very different way of
thinking about photography.
Roaming around maybe
at the farmer's market
or at a restaurant or wherever
you happen to see food
and just trying to
snap a quick photo
and hope you catch
that magical moment.
So I was somewhere in between
these two worlds of thought.
Like I loved being out
at the farmer's market
and getting some
great shot of a girl
in a red dress behind
the red apples and think,
oh, I caught that moment.
You know, that was satisfying.
But also, I really
enjoyed the styling
and the setup of the photo.
So through grad
school, I was sort
of playing with those two
sides of my interests.
This was my thesis project
when I was in grad school.
And I had read an
article about this chef,
his name was Will Goldfarb.
Has anyone ever heard of him?
He has a couple of cookbooks
out, he's still working.
So I read this article
about him and he
made these amazing desserts
that I was totally inspired by.
And I thought I have to go
to this guy's restaurant.
So I went down to Soho
and I just got a seat
at the bar one night by myself.
And he was behind the bar.
And I started talking to him.
And I'm very shy, this was
like not in my comfort zone.
But I was like
really drawn to what
he was doing with food,
and colors, and ideas,
and translating that all
in the kitchen space.
And so I asked him
pretty bluntly,
I said I'm a
photography student,
I'm looking to photograph some
really interesting desserts,
would you be open to
letting me photograph
what you've made here.
And he was really receptive and
so nice and invited me to come.
And I spent months going
into the restaurant
and photographing his creations.
So my final project was
in the form of a book.
And it was two images
next to each other.
So the one on the
right is his creation.
And then I use all the
ingredients from that dish
and did my own sort of collage
interpretation of that dish.
So those are the
ingredients that
go into that dish in a sort
of abstract presentation.
Here's a couple more of those.
So again, this one, the
citrus and the vanilla,
and the berries, they
all go into that dessert
that he created
that's on the right.
But this is sort
of the early signs
of my interest in diptychs,
two images that really work
together to tell a story about
food and breaking down a recipe
and thinking about it--
not only in terms of ideas,
but in terms of color,
and form, and shape,
and thinking of it in a very
graphic way that's tangible,
right?
You order that dessert
in a restaurant
and unless you read
the menu description,
you have no idea what's
really in there, right?
So I love the idea of
breaking it down in image form
to see what went into it.
So also around that
time I was doing
a lot of photo journalistic
work in restaurants
and shooting chefs.
And, again, it's
that idea of catching
and getting lucky in the
moment and catching the photo.
This was a more setup shot
that I did in a restaurant,
just with a piece
of black Velvet
in a window in a dining room
using some very small flashes
that I had brought with me.
And I was really
drawn to the colors
and the graphic notion of
these shapes and forms working
together to show
what I was hoping
would be a more interesting
display of a charcuterie plate.
But, of course, it's
the chef's plating
and his idea that went into
the way that dish looks.
But I was trying to really
capture the essence of it.
During that time,
I was also shooting
a lot of photojournalist
type work
as a volunteer photographer
at the James Beard Foundation.
And I would go, maybe,
one night a month
and they would have a
volunteer photographer
in the kitchen with all these
amazing and famous chefs
that would come through.
And I would get to be
right next to them.
It was so small, like much
smaller than this kitchen.
It was actually the
apartment of James Beard,
he was a contemporary
of Julia Child.
And his home was turned
into a foundation and also
a very interesting dining space
if you're ever in New York.
But anyway, that was a good way
for me to build my portfolio
and get exposure to a
lot of different chefs
and types of food and connect
with chefs that I could then
go to their
restaurants in New York
and do some more photography.
This was my first magazine
cover of "Edible Manhattan,"
some soup in a window.
And, again, it's that kind
of photo journalistic type
shot that is somewhat setup
but also photo journalistic.
And this was my first shot
in the "New York Times,"
which was a big goal of mine.
This was in 2007 and I was
so excited to photograph
this restaurant.
And it ran in the
dining section.
So when I finished grad
school, I started teaching.
So I had a degree in
photography and Photoshop
was my favorite
part of all of that.
And so I started teaching
digital photography
and Photoshop at
FIT, the Fashion
Institute of Technology.
And I was teaching photography
and also freelancing
as a food photographer,
mostly food photographer.
I have some other
kinds of photography
too during that time.
This was a restaurant shot
that I did as a freelancer.
And if you'll take a look
at the style and lighting
of these shots, black
backgrounds, white backgrounds,
bright lighting, harsh shadows.
So I'll just fast
forward to what came
next is driving up Highway 84.
I don't know if you
guys have ever driven up
to Skyline and Woodside,
it's only about a half
an hour from here.
But my husband got a job
here about seven years ago
and we came out.
We were living in
New York and came out
on a whirlwind weekend.
We didn't know where
we were going to live.
And we're just like looking
at all these different ads.
We thought we probably
live in Mountain View.
And just by chance,
we found an ad
for this really cool
cabin up in Woodside.
And as we're
driving this road, I
was like, there's no way
we're going to live up here.
This road is crazy.
Can you imagine
driving this every day?
But once we got there, we
got a look at the view,
and we're like, OK, how
far is this to the office?
Maybe the road isn't that bad.
And it's like a total 180 from
living in Brooklyn, right?
To go to the woods, even if it
is technically Silicon Valley.
And as we were leaving,
they said, you know, there
is actually like a small
studio on the property
that you could
use for your work.
Because we were thinking, oh,
the cabin is a little small.
I don't know if it
will work for us.
And then the studio
part was like, oh, OK.
This could really work.
I could see my work taking
a different turn here.
So there's something
about the light here
that was very special.
So because we're so
close to the coast,
there's a lot of fog
that's rolling in.
So I don't know if you can
see that fog rolling by,
but that's just sort of like the
view right out of the kitchen.
And the deck is right there
in front of the kitchen.
And if you study photography
and never used a soft box,
having that soft light
is really hard to achieve
and a really desirable type
of light for shooting food.
So I thought, we have like
a lightbox in the sky here,
this is amazing.
I don't even need
studio lights anymore.
I can just shoot outside.
It's like all right here.
The light is amazing.
And then also just being so
close to the coast and being,
maybe, California
everything was so golden.
The light was really golden,
which I love for photographing.
SCOTT: While she
is advancing, I had
a question about the lighting.
So how much of a
lighting do you have
to do nowadays with
technology, the old school
way of setting up versus how
much can you do after the fact?
ERIN GLEESON: Yeah
good question.
SCOTT: And again, Google
Photos does a lot of great--
and we used to work with
lighting apps in the back
and it's much easier, but
is it a better result?
ERIN GLEESON: Yeah.
I mean, there's so much that
you can do now after the fact.
You can really kind of
save yourself, which
is good when you're learning.
But I try to get as much
as I can into the shot.
There's always a lot more color,
quality, and detail in the shot
if you could just get it
right there in the camera.
You can fix a lot
after the fact.
Even though I love
Photoshop, I don't use it
so much to fix the photos
or retouch them that much.
It's usually just kind
of an overall color
cast shift or adding a little
bit of contrast or cropping,
things like that.
I'll show you how I use
Photoshop in a different more
illustrative way also.
But for shooting, I love
to get it in the shot
as much as I can.
Yeah.
So here's just another shot.
I started playing around
with cooking outside.
And we had just gotten this
membership to a CSA box,
a community supported
agriculture farm box.
Has anybody subscribed
to one of these?
They're great, yeah.
So some of them
you can choose what
you get each week, and some of
them you just kind of get a box
and you're not really sure
what's going to show up.
And so we're getting this box,
and every week I thought--
we actually got to choose eight
items each week of a limited
offering.
And I was always choosing
the most colorful things
that I thought would be
really fun to photograph.
And that was really the impetus
for the whole Forest Feast
Project.
So I started out
thinking, OK, I'm going
to just start taking photos.
I've never worked with
chefs in the Bay Area.
I'm going to just start cooking
some really simple things
myself to take photos of so
that I can make a new portfolio.
Because in the past,
I've always worked
with chefs who had
made the dishes,
and I would photograph them.
But I thought I love
cooking, I grew up cooking,
I can make some
really simple things,
I'll keep it under five
ingredients, simple steps.
And I didn't really know
where I was going with this,
but I thought I'd start
a website or a blog.
And I called it the
Forest Feast since we just
moved to the forest and
I love alliteration.
And I just started
posting photos.
And the first couple
of photos, it's
pretty clear that I didn't
know what I was doing yet.
I was just really experimenting
with these local ingredients
and trying to figure it out.
And then one day, I was
getting sort of tired
of photographing things
on the tablecloth or just
on my wooden table.
And I had met with a couple
editors in San Francisco who
said those black and white,
harsh, light, slick looking
photos weren't really
the vibe they were going
for here for west
coast magazines
and maybe cookbooks
that were here
that I was hoping to shoot
other people's cookbooks.
And they said, we just
need a little bit more
of a natural vibe.
And I was so tired
of my wooden table.
I thought, I'm just
going to walk outside.
So one day, I had a
plate of acorn squash
that I had cooked that
had come in that CSA box.
And I was just walking
around and I just
started putting the
plate down in the forest
like in our backyard.
Looking for old stumps and
mossy logs and a pile of leaves.
I was trying to bring in kind
of like a natural element,
but also different colors
and textures and shapes that
might give it a different look.
This is an early version
of my Forest Feast website.
And I just treated it as a blog.
I was sharing recipes,
but I got bored
by just typing out the recipe.
And I thought, I could
show this visually.
Maybe I should make a diagram
and show the ingredients,
sort of like I had been
doing with my cookbook
that I did in grad school,
sort of showing the pieces that
go into the final dish.
I thought we're so saturated
with recipes online,
especially if you want to
make something for dinner.
You just want to scroll
through and be like,
I have that in my fridge.
I think I can make that.
And if you see a photo of it
rather than reading through it
all, it might be more
immediate and also
more interesting to look at.
And I was also just
inspired by my space,
being in this cabin, a
different environment.
I was worried that
my biggest career
accomplishments might have
been behind me in New York.
It was hard to leave so many
years of building a photography
business in New York, and
then just leave and think
what's next?
But I was pretty inspired
by this new space.
So this was the first
photo that was my "aha"
moment on my Forest Feast blog.
And it's that acorn squash.
And I was wandering
around putting it
on all these different surfaces.
And there had been
this tree that died.
And they took it down.
And I just set the cutting
board down on that tree
and I thought, all the colors
and the shapes of that log
really are mimicking the
shapes and colors and textures
of that acorn squash.
And this is so much more
interesting than my dining room
table.
And so, I think that was maybe
my third post on my blog.
And the first couple were
just like, "A bowl of fruit."
But this is the first
one where I was like, OK,
maybe this is a good
direction to try and explore.
So I started doing a
bunch more like this.
And instead of
just typing it out,
I made a photo of
the ingredients
that went into the dish.
And I popped that into Photoshop
and I added my handwriting
on top because I couldn't
find a font that I loved.
And I added just a little
bit of typewriter font
to fill in some details.
And then I put the two
together to make that diptych.
Like I said, I had always kind
of thought in diptych form.
I loved these two images
that work together.
And they seemed to
lend themselves well
to a website or a blog.
So these are a few more
examples of some of the photos.
So, again, this is a
garlicy kale Caesar salad
with polenta croutons.
And I thought that mossy
log worked well with it.
So here's the recipe
page for that salad.
So I used an old book
because I'm always
looking for some sort of either
very dark or very light surface
to add the text on
top of in my shot.
So I put a little piece of
watercolor paper at the top.
And remember, I had always loved
watercolor painting, right?
But I always saw it as a hobby,
painting little postcards
and mailing them to people.
And I always thought as
a professional artist,
you should probably
choose one medium.
I chose photography so I'm
going to stick with that.
But I never really
thought about calling
myself an Illustrator
or a painter,
but I thought you know what?
We just moved to the woods.
I don't know what I'm
doing with my life
and I'm going to start
putting my paintings right
on top of my photos
and see what happens.
It was fun.
But I started to
post them online
and people really
kind of responded
to that illustrative
component of it.
So you can see in Photoshop
I layered in the kale Caesar
painted font.
So I just painted that
on paper and scanned it
and then put it in
using Photoshop,
along with all my handwriting.
And then again that
diptych, so the two images
working together.
So here's just an example of
a few of my little watercolor
paintings, which you'll
see I'm wearing today.
I made it into some clothes too.
I'm wearing the book
to the book talk.
Here's a couple more
examples of recipes
that I was working with.
So something that I
was really drawn to
and, I think, in part by
my art school training,
I was also studying sculpture
when I was in school.
So I was trying to
think of these plates
as little sculptures.
And I feel like that's
the way Will Goldfarb,
the chef that I had
photographed the dishes of,
I imagine that he
thought of his plates
as a little sculpture
or little pieces of art.
So thinking about the
dish more structurally,
I thought maybe there's
more interesting ways
that I can cut things
and layer things
and think about different shapes
and textures and colors going
together for a dish, not only
for the way it might taste
but for the way I might look
when you're presenting it,
right?
It doesn't have to be that hard.
You don't have to be a
traditionally trained chef
to be able to make a
beautiful dish, I think.
And I have not gone to
culinary school, by the way.
Remember.
I make very simple recipes
and I'm inspired by color.
So this dish, I
chopped the watermelon
into big round slices.
And then I just
removed the rind.
And then used the whole
watermelon slab as the basis
for this dish.
So you could use
a large watermelon
and cut it into pie
pieces and share it,
or you can use those
many watermelons
and just make a single
one for each person.
But it's a fun and maybe
slightly different presentation
than you may have seen
before inspired by a very
traditional summer salad,
which is watermelon
with some sort of cheese
and herb, usually feta.
But I tossed in some mozzarella,
fresh mozzarella slices
because I like the
round shape that mimiced
the round shape of the melon.
And then I was also playing
around with different styling,
just trying to take
things off the plate.
So in my photography, I
was shooting this right
before Thanksgiving.
And there's all these beautiful
fall leaves on the ground.
And I thought, I
can't find a plate
that I like really
that much for these.
They're white, they don't
look good on a white plate.
I'm just going to try one
of those leaves out there.
So technically, you could
serve it like that if you
found some sort of edible leaf.
But it worked well
for the photo.
Here's some apricot bites.
Again, just thinking
about different colors
that go really well together.
So the orange and
the red and the green
all playing off of each
other, but also super simple.
So about six months into having
this blog online is on Tumblr,
it started to really
gain some traction
and I started getting
people reposting
my recipes on their blogs and
giving comments on my blog.
And I was like, oh my
goodness, this is so exciting.
I didn't expect anybody to
see this except for the editor
that I might send a link to.
And I really didn't know
anything about food blogging.
I didn't even really follow
food blogs that closely.
But about six months
into it, a literary agent
reached out, somebody
from New York.
And she said, I saw
your blog online.
And I think you should
turn it into a book.
And I said, are you sure?
I don't know if
I'm ready for that.
And she said, no, you're ready.
Look at your images
right next to each other.
Those diptychs, those
two vertical images
right next to each other,
they lend themselves perfectly
to the pages of a book.
Like it's already a book.
Let's turn it into one.
And I really loved
some of the clients
that she had worked with
before who are bloggers
turned cookbook authors.
So I said, OK, let's do it.
So she's been amazing.
And so about within
a year of that--
I guess about maybe six months
after that, I got a book deal.
And then it took about a year
to create my first book, which
is called "The Forest Feast."
And here it is.
So just all vegetarian
recipes and completely
inspired by living in the woods.
Here's a behind the scenes
shot of my cover shoot.
It's basically just a piece of
plywood and a kitchen chair.
And I'm standing on that chair
totally hand-held, no tripod
or anything, all natural light.
And my editor was on the
cell phone in New York.
I'm always shooting in
that late in the day
time, about 4:30 or so, when
that golden hour kind of light
comes in.
So for her it was
7:30 at night, so she
was at home with her kids.
And I'm taking pictures
and texting them to her
and she's like move the
tomato over a little bit
and pull that plate
down over there.
So a little bit of
trial and error, and we
got the cover shot.
That was during the cover shot.
But this is a one woman show.
It is me in the backyard.
And there's the end pages.
We decided to use all
those illustrations
as the end pages for the book.
Again, the dress.
So here's a few photos
that are from that book.
And I just thought I'd explain
the Photoshop use in the recipe
side.
That was just a big empty
white piece of handmade paper
that I bought at
the paper store.
I tacked it up on the
fence with the thought
that that would be the title.
So I was always trying
to in the real world
trying to think about, OK,
I'm looking at this shot.
Where is the title going to go?
Where is my handwriting
going to go?
I'm always trying to leave
room for arrows and text
while I'm shooting.
Here's the bay potatoes.
I picked some bay out back.
And, again, trying to
think of those colors,
I think layering potatoes
like that in a pan
has certainly been done so much.
And I was just trying
to mix up the colors
a little bit by adding some
sweet potato and red onion.
There are some stuffed
tomatoes, trying
to think about different
ways to cut the tomatoes
and create vessels out of
different types of vegetables
to create an interesting
presentation.
It's also vegetarian
and colorful and easy.
And then I also for the book
did some more illustrated kind
of sauce and
dressing type recipes
that were all illustrated.
I'm a visual learner,
but I find it easier
to look at the picture
of all the ingredients
and have a sense of how
to make a dish rather
than reading a lot of
steps or a lot of text.
Here's a couple of cutting
techniques that I drew out.
And, again, this page is
totally made in Photoshop.
So that brought me to
our first baby, Ezra.
So I was pregnant with
him on the book tour
for the first book.
And soon after, he was born.
And soon after that, my
editors reached out and said,
we think you should
adapt your book for kids.
It's so visual, it already
makes sense for kids
to be able to look at these
pictures and make something.
So we took 20 recipes
out of the first book
and I created 20 new ones
and we made the "Forest Feast
For Kids," and that
came out in 2016.
I had some kids over,
friends that we knew,
and they helped me
cook on the deck.
We did a workshop.
And they gave me some really
useful feedback, actually.
This one little boy said
that he needed more examples
of how to cut things.
He was interested
in cutting things.
So there was a whole--
I think I included it in here.
Yes, this was the cutting
techniques, inspired by Jacob.
He said just knowing which way
to start and if you peel first
or after.
And so I thought, how could
I show that really visually
and make it easy, not
only for me, but for kids?
So it's aimed at kids who
are 8 to 12 years old.
Here's a couple more
photos from that book.
So it could be a carrot salad
or it could be a rainbow carrot
salad.
We're lucky in California to
have such colorful produce
that's pretty accessible.
I know right now we're getting
rainbow carrots in our farm
box, like this week.
So here's an example of
how I set up that shot.
Again, thinking about a
high or low contrast item
to have the text
to go over, which
is that white piece of canvas,
layering the ingredients
on top, and then
individually painting
different elements that
would add to the diagram
effect of the recipe.
A little bit of handwriting
and a little bit
of typewriter text.
Here's a peanut
butter avocado shake,
trying to get those
greens in the kids.
We have two kids.
So now I know how hard it is
to get them to eat vegetables.
So then soon after that--
we love having people
over and I feel
like everything that went
into creating my first book
was very much
entertaining inspired.
So it felt like a
natural next step
to do an entertaining
book, which
is the "Forest Feast
Gatherings," which you guys all
have in front of you.
And that really started
with these dinner parties
on our deck where I was
experimenting, making dishes,
or having shoot days where
I made tons of dishes
and needed friends to come over
and help us eat everything.
But eating outside I feel like
always makes everything better.
So ideas for outdoor
entertaining and hosting.
Everything in this book
is laid out in menus.
So if you're hosting
a summer dinner party,
here's like five or six
things that you could make.
And if you don't
have that much time,
just make these three of
them and buy these things.
And so sort of
hosting tips to make
it easier because I think it
can be hard to entertain, right?
It's intimidating to
think, oh my gosh,
people are coming
over to my house.
I have to clean it, I have
to get everything ready,
there's so much prep, I have
to start buying the groceries
days in advance, I have to
take the afternoon off work
to make it all happen.
And I don't think you have to.
So I was trying to give lots
of really practical ideas
for how you could have people
over and connect with people
over good plant based food
and not stress yourself out
too much.
So here's the brunch menu.
It's a holiday
cocktail party menu
and I have some
little DIYs in there,
like how to make that
little floral garland
that you can hang.
This is an example of
one of the spreads.
I feel like this book is,
to me, artistically kind
of an evolution
of my first book.
There's a lot more art
and painting and kind
of like a floral
styling that's in the--
yeah, there you go.
You have the page
open right there.
There's a lot more of an
artistic element to it,
I think.
It evolved even more
from the first book.
And I even included a little
painting, a cabin painting.
And for the contents
page, you can
see I just pulled like mossy
sticks and leaves and things
on the side and layered
those on the edges,
just to make the page just a
little bit more interesting.
Here's me cooking in
our little kitchen.
And there's an aerial view at
the bottom of the left hand
page of where we live.
Even though it's only
about 35 minutes from here,
it's pretty densely wooded.
Here's one of the
recipes from the book,
zaatar roasted carrots.
I'm always trying to find
interesting elements of a dish
that maybe you don't
have in your kitchen,
but are pretty
readily available.
So zaatar is a
great spice blend.
Has anyone cooked
with zaatar before?
Yeah, it's good, right?
It's a blend of a few
different herbs and spices.
And anyway, I can find it at
my local grocery store often.
If I'm at Safeway or Whole
Foods or one of my local grocery
stores, if I can't find a
certain ingredient I think,
OK, other people
aren't going to be
able to find that either so
I'm not going to include it.
Here's a roasted
a eggplant salad
using some edible nastirtium
flowers, which we actually have
from the Google garden today.
They're so beautiful.
Here's a rice noodle bar.
So a lot of my
thinking also, which
is what you'll see that
we're going to sample later,
is so often we have
friends over for dinner
and people have different
dietary restrictions
or preferences.
And I wanted to give
some options for things
that you could serve that could
work for any number of things.
So the rice noodle bar
is gluten free and vegan,
which is a good one.
We're going to have
the polenta bar here
today and also the endive bar.
Those are all vegan
and gluten free.
I also has some fun DIY things,
like floral arranging in here
in the book.
So this is a small
floral arrangement
that you can make just using
scotch tape and a bowl.
Here's one more shot of the
deck and just sitting outside.
This is a shot, if you don't
mind playing the video,
of that aerial shot.
So a friend with
a drone came over
and took this view off
the deck just to give
a sense of where we are.
Deep in the woods, but as we're
looking out, we're looking west
and that's like Pescadero,
Half Moon Bay area out there.
And yeah, it's just
such a beautiful area.
And it's been so inspiring
to me in so many ways
being in California.
And being surrounded
by trees I think
changes your energy somehow.
For me, it was very
quieting to leave the city
and be suddenly in a very
different kind of quiet space.
Can we go to the
next slide please?
It took me in a very
different place creatively.
I feel like if I didn't
have that shift of space,
both mentally and
physically, I might not
have had the creative shift
to be able to even come up
with this idea.
It's like so different than what
I was doing before in New York.
And I think my vision
of what I hoped
I might become that year when I
was 22 and I moved to New York
to be a photographer, what
I thought my goal was then
is very different than
what I ended up doing now.
But I think I like this better.
So you never know.
So "Forest Feast Gatherings"
came out in 2016.
And I feel like after--
let's see, five or six
years in the woods,
two babies later, we were kind
of ready for some even more
new inspiration.
So we decided to shift
it up a little bit.
My husband had a three
month sabbatical, last fall.
A year ago fall.
And we decided to go to
Europe and spend three months
traveling with our two kids.
So we had a baby and
a toddler at the time.
And we decided that we would go
to Barcelona first to get back
a little bit of that city vibe.
So we spent a whole
month in Barcelona.
Then we traveled along
the French Riviera.
And then we did a big
road trip around Sicily.
And also hit up northern
Italy, the Liguria area.
And then we ended the trip
with about a month in Portugal.
And so that whole
experience, I went into it
with the hope of making
a Mediterranean cookbook.
So through that whole trip,
I Was taking lots of photos
and tasting lots of things,
of course, tasting vegetarian
things, but keeping an eye on
the traditional meaty things
to think about how I could
shift things to be vegetarian.
Take traditional local dishes,
but put a twist on them
to be vegetarian.
There's just me having a
glass of wine in Cinque Terre
having a grand old time.
Having some coffee.
And this is what I actually
looked like most of the time,
baby sleeping strapped to my
belly with a camera in hand.
But it was an adventure.
And I learned so much
about food and travel
and exploring local flavors.
This was the farmer's market
in Antibes in southern France,
like right near Nice and Cannes.
Has anyone been there before?
Antibes?
Yeah.
So beautiful.
It's amazing.
Everyone should go there.
But we stayed right next to
the farmer's market there.
And we would go every day.
And we kept buying the radishes.
They had these
beautiful radishes
that we would buy
with the butter
from the farmers market, that
probably was made not too far
away.
And the flavors were so
intense, but everything was just
so local and so plant inspired,
even though, of course,
there's lots of
meat in French food,
but the use of vegetables,
even in winter,
was very impressive to me.
So I took note of
different foods grown there
and then took it
back to our cabin
in the woods to
develop recipes based
on inspired by, not only the
dishes, but the produce grown
in the places that we visited.
So this was a dish inspired
by that Antibes market.
They had the most incredible
cherry tomatoes all
on the vine, just like all lined
up perfectly at the market.
And so I roasted
them and put them
with some torn
mozzarella and capers
and a little bit of lemon zest
and some really good olive oil
sprinkled on top and
flaky salt. And you just
put it on a little
piece of French bread,
and it's delicious
and so simple.
And here's another example.
So these are recipes
in my upcoming book
that will be out in
September, and it's called
the "Forest Feast Travels."
And it's totally based on
this whole trip that we took.
So this was part of
our Sicily road trip.
And this is at the top of
Mount Etna, the active volcano.
And this was a region known
for its honey and pistachio
production, even at the
top, like in the lodge
at the top of the volcano.
They had a whole honey tasting.
It was all local honey.
It was so cool.
So I thought, what can I do
with honey and pistachios?
And in my other books, I always
have a shortbread recipe,
so I thought I'm
going to combine
the honey and the pistachios
into my shortbread recipe
and have that be
inspired by Mount Etna.
And there's that shortbread.
And I'm always like
scavenging for dishes
and looking for
different backdrops
for a lot of the
backdrops in the next book
because I didn't want them to
be on moss because we weren't
talking about the
woods as much anymore.
I printed out large posters
of a lot of the photos
that I took while on this trip.
So I intentionally
while we were traveling
took photos of
cool looking walls,
and tile, and rock, and just
all kinds of textural backdrops.
And then printed
those out really big
and I used those
as my backdrops.
Because it just wasn't feasible
to shoot all the food while
we were traveling.
This is Pasta alla Norma
inspired by Tower Mina.
Here's a beet pasta where
you just grate raw beats
and mix them in.
This is the pasta making class
in Italy that was so much fun.
I had tried many times to
make pasta from scratch.
Has anyone made
pasta from scratch?
Yeah, good results?
I found it so challenging.
I don't know why.
I just couldn't get the
texture quite right.
Like all by hand, I didn't
want to use a pasta maker
attachment or anything.
But anyways, I took
this class and it's just
eggs, flour, and a very
small splash of water.
And that's all you need.
It's delicious.
So Chef Luca in Motorola, Italy
helped me with the fresh egg
pasta recipe.
A couple more shots
from the book.
So I did some paintings kind
of inspired by the title,
especially Lisbon had
amazing tile everywhere.
So this is a shot from a wall
in Lisbon, that tile backdrop.
And then I used
that as inspiration
and also painted some tile like
backdrops that were watercolor.
And, again, sort of mimicking
the watercolor pattern
at the top based on the tile
that I used in the shot.
Here's an action shot
shooting in Italy.
This is a little video if
you don't mind playing.
Everybody was drinking spritzes
in Italy, aperol spritzes,
which is like this bright orange
liqueur with a little champagne
or prosecco and
a little seltzer.
So I had to include that.
I did a slight
variation on it, but it
was inspired by
these aperol spritzes
that we tried in Italy.
We did a really fun wine
tasting tour in Italy,
hiking in the vineyards
above the ocean.
A very, very small
family wine producer
that we tried their wines.
And there's the cover of the
book, "Forest Feast Travels"
that comes out in September.
So then just as a continuation
of my Forest Feast work,
I also have some
stationery which
has been really fun to
develop and a different kind
of creative outlet for me.
I'm thinking about how my
illustration and watercolors
can be used to create different
products that aren't cookbooks,
but still maybe help inspire
people to cook or take
notes about food.
I'm just always
trying to encourage
people to think about being
creative in your daily life.
It's not always so
easy to do that,
but I think there are
certain things that
can help like cook books.
They inspire me.
These were some placements that
were made with my watercolors.
And some more kind of product
sketches that I'm currently
working on for dishes and
tablecloths and things
that I'm dreaming about
but haven't made yet.
Except for I did
make some clothes.
This is a photo that I took
of a really big orange tree
in Sacramento.
It was a really
dense orange tree.
And I took a one huge
shot, one photo of it.
And it was big enough to be
able to blow up and cover
a small couch with, which
I did for our house.
And then I made us some
clothes to wear to a wedding
last summer to.
It's a little
ridiculous, but fun.
So the cool part about this
whole "Forest Feast" adventure
that I've been on
in sharing the books
is that now it's
in 10 languages.
And while we were traveling,
we saw the book in, I think,
every country in that language.
So it's so fun to
be able to see.
And especially
online, nothing makes
me happier than seeing people
making recipes from the book
and tagging them so
that I can see them.
And I feel like it's just
spreading the vegetable
love across the world.
So I guess when I think
about what my goal is
with the "Forest
Feast" and what I
hope to do by
creating these books
and sharing my artwork is
really to inspire people
to get together and eat good
food, good healthy food that
is plant based, fruit based,
grown locally, if possible.
It's not only good for our
bodies but good for our planet.
And my goal is to do that in
an artful and approachable way
to make it easy for people
to not only eat that way,
but to do it together.
Thank you very much.
SCOTT: Thank you.
[CLAPPING]
So I have one quick
question for you
and then I have a
question for the audience.
So if you have
three tips that you
could pass along to probably
many of our Instagramers
out there.
When they're at restaurants
or they're in a cafe
and they want to take
a picture of with food,
what are some of the
things that you think about
to tell the story--
because we don't have
time for lighting booths
and all that, to tell
the story as you've
done so eloquently, to
capture that moment,
and to get the best contrast?
Are there any tips
you can pass on?
ERIN GLEESON: Sure.
Yeah.
So go at lunchtime.
Sit by the window.
And do an overhead shot.
So I think dishes
always look good
when they're lit from either
behind or from the side.
So if you can place your--
so if this is my dish, and
this is the window right here,
I might place my dish
right here and shoot
from right here or
from right here so
that I get a little bit of side
light or a little bit of light
from behind.
If it seems a little
too dark on one side,
sometimes I hold up a white
plate or a white napkin
to bounce a little bit
of light back on there.
But the portrait mode is
obviously great for food shots
to get a really close up.
But I think I often go
for the overhead look.
And I usually
don't shoot square.
But if you do, you
could center the dish.
But if you're shooting with the
rectangle shape for Instagram,
then I like to balance
it out somehow.
So sort of have it be
slightly off center.
You can crop the plate
maybe by three quarters.
And maybe pull a couple of
other elements into the corners
to kind of balance it out.
So I'm often looking
for an offset balance.
So if my plate is
towards the middle,
have maybe a napkin down here
and some flowers up here.
And then shoot it
right from overhead.
Or move that plate over and have
something down in the corner
to sort of balance it out.
So you're looking for
balance in the photo,
but not super symmetrical.
I like things to be
slightly off center.
SCOTT: Huge round of
applause for Erin Gleeson.
Thank you.
ERIN GLEESON: Thank you.
SCOTT: Good job.
[CLAPPING]